foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
is he gay
are you [__] serious this is the
hard-hitting stuff that's the right wing
is going with because they can't impeach
Joe Biden
for Hunter Biden dick pics is that is
that really what we're gonna do
that's really where and we're gonna
believe some guy who didn't pass a
polygraph test which I you know honestly
I don't give a [__] about the polygraph
test the thing that I care about is in
this interview with Tucker Carlson with
this Gantt what the [__] his name
what's this guy's name it doesn't matter
what this guy's name is he's full of
[__]
you can tell he's full of [__] but what
does it matter even if Barack Obama was
doing coke and smoking crack and having
a homosexual sex what does it matter if
Barack Obama is bisexual or if he's gay
what the [__] does it matter
this is the best they have folks even
I'm gonna show you a clip of 10 pool
even like this is
this is really dumb this is really dumb
even temples like this is really dumb
but Tim pulls like we should say it
anyways I mean we say dumb [__] all the
time we continue to say dumb stuff so
why not say the dumbest [__] on Earth it
is it is laughable
that somehow
Tucker Carlson
is the lead hard-hitting commentator on
the right
when he invites this chucklehead on
that which all all the [__] that this
guy said has has been debunked time and
time again he claims in 1999 that him
and Barack Obama did cocaine smoke crack
and had sex twice like consensually
right
that that's and and of course Ben
Shapiro this morning too is trying to
trying to equate this guy's bogus ass
story with aging Carol
what the [__] are you why how what kind
of nuts tan balls did these [__]
right Wingers have
and it's not about the right Wingers and
the commentators okay understand this
understand this it's about Their
audience okay it's about Their audience
the the Eminem's thing that wasn't
enough Bud Light oh my God Bud Light
wasn't up and then they found out Kid
Rock was still drinking Bud Light and
they're like oh that sucks there goes
that thing there goes that thing we're
trying to get rid of oh Disney hate they
[__] hate black mermaids oh my God
there's no such thing in the world as a
black mermaid don't you know
now it's now it's Obama's gay are you
serious
not to mention you're you're pinning
your entire political hopes in the house
and in the Senate on
Joe Biden didn't take a five million
dollar bribe but we think there might be
evidence even though we don't have it
and we can't get it and we probably
won't
and we want to impeach him but we're
going to shut down the government first
and we're gonna call it coveted
lockdowns because that's what we lie a
lot so that's what we're gonna do these
people are [__] ridiculous
folks when you when you elect a
political party and to power anywhere I
don't care if it's in the House of
Representatives Senate President United
States all the way down to the [__]
dog catcher
when you when you put these people in
power and and their entire political
movement is based on lies and
affiliation it's gonna fall apart fast
quick and in a hurry and I know it feels
like it's not fast enough but the
Republican party is really it's an old
party
it's old it's over 150 years old
and it's taking this long to get to this
moment where they're gonna crash this
[__] in a matter of a decade
Republican parties did it's [__] dead
think about this for a second think
about it for a second their main go-to
for the next three weeks I'm not
[__] you in the next three weeks Fox
News is going to be talking about this
oan Newsmax it's go
Obama gay
as if it [__] makes it I don't even
give a [__] if Tucker Carlson's gay
which it appears that he's been a
closeted gay man for a long time but who
gives a [__] if Tucker Carlson wants to
be closeted fine whatever I don't give a
shack I care less I just don't want him
to be a [__] fascist
I give a [__] less who he wants to Bone
I don't care I don't give a [__]
whatever you want to do Tucker if you
want to have a beer to marry a woman and
then continue to have relationships on
the side I don't know if that's why you
invited this guy on your show or not
maybe I I don't know I have no idea I
don't give a [__] could care less
who Tucker Carlson wants to bone
it doesn't matter and it shouldn't
matter who Barack Obama had sex with
consensual sex with
even though it's a bogus [__] story
not even close to being true it's
[__] wild [__] because Tucker Carlson
says in this interview he's like and the
guy took a polygraph test but he fails
to tell his imbecile audience because
that's really the story here is the
imbecile audience and I'm getting there
but he tells his imbecile audience the
end cells you know the people who are
terrified that they're gay man I watch
porn one time and there was a big old
wiener in there and man it really
confused me uh got me all in my feels it
was weird
those types those types you know they
get really they're really [__]
terrified that they might go out in
public get out of their mom's basement a
time or two and see a pretty woman and
that pretty woman might like them and
then they might take them home and find
out oh at one point this woman was a man
and that makes me gay they're [__]
terrified of their own shadow these
people are not [__] these people are
not the Pillar of Strength in our
democracy these people are weak feeble
little in cells
they're fragile white men who are being
pumped these lies by Tucker Carlson and
Ben Shapiro
the daily wire Twitter Elon it goes on
and on and on it's it's a whole in-cell
Army
and the and the most sex they see and
get is with their own [__] you know
Rosie Palm her her four sisters
and her brother
and it's all the action these people get
Tucker Carlson knows that there ain't
that listen the Fox News audience is not
listening to Tucker Carlson anymore
folks that's why Tucker's doing this
[__]
Tucker found out that he can't do the
Russia stuff anymore
and he can't do the typical Fox News you
know
old crusty white dude the old wrinkly
ball sack type fear he's got to tap into
the incel Elon Musk type fear right oh
man what happens if you're gay
who gives a [__] if Obama I don't give a
[__] I could care less
if Barack Obama has had sex with someone
consensual saying I don't care I don't
give a [__]
Obama is not the president we are you
gonna impeach
Obama now is that what is that what you
guys want because I mean you're not
successful at impeaching Biden the
current president so maybe maybe just
maybe they're trying like oh Obama gay
and Peach him
I don't know I mean I think you can
impeach a former president can't you
like after their left office I think
that's a thing I don't know
oh my God I mean they're just not having
much success
and impeaching Joe Biden for you know
evidence that they can't find that
doesn't exist so maybe they'll go out
and get evidence that's not real that's
bogus that's all [__] and impeach
Obama
but think about this Obama was a
two-term president he was elected twice
with the popular emulatorial vote
twice
against Two Old Guard establishment type
Republicans not not trumpers
McCain and Romney are
so far uh pass being trumpers don't get
it wrong that they're still Republicans
okay okay
but they're definitely not trumpers
but that was damn near eight years ago
when Barack Obama left office
almost eight goddamn years ago
and this this event that they're talking
about happened in 1999 which it didn't
happen it's all [__]
there's no evidence other than this guy
saying it and there's actually evidence
to the contrary because this guy's a
[__] fraud he's he's been I think he
got a 17-year sentence somewhere
for committing fraud forgery this guy
has a history
of lying
he's been convicted of it several times
and this is and and and and and he took
a polygram test apparently there was a
news outlet that was going to pay him a
hundred thousand dollars for the story
if he took a polygraph test and passed
and he failed the polygraph
Tucker fails to mention that of course
because the in-cell Army that's
listening to him would really man those
kind of facts would really [__] up their
their the two brain cells that they're
trying to rub together while listening
to Tucker Carlson feed them full of a
bunch of [__]
you know what's exciting about this this
sh this should this should excite you
this should excite you
Tucker Carlson is supposed to be their
[__] Goebbels is supposed to be their
king of propaganda folks
I'm he's supposed to be their king of
propaganda and he's forcing all these
commentators probably for the next two
or three weeks to talk about how Obama's
gay
what
that's that's your strategy
that's your strategy for National
narrative
is to think that the majority of the
country is gonna give two [__]
if Obama's gay
what the f oh man
I just I can't
I can't even describe to you how much of
a a blunder this is this is the same the
same Bud Light blender right them going
on and on and on and on and on and on
and on and on about queer beer right
because it was the beer that was
supposed to make you gay and like as if
being gay and drinking beer are bad
things I don't understand it like who
gives a [__] yeah drinking beer is fun
I mean there's a lot of gay people that
have a lot of fun there are a lot of
they're a lot of fun
so what the [__] the problem what what
are you so upset about people having fun
what the [__] are you what what are you
doing you think America you think the
American people
are gonna be on the side of these
[__] chuckleheads
telling you you can't drink beer I mean
literally literally Ted Cruz is on Fox
News and oh and like Joe Biden's telling
me I can only drink two beers well he
can kiss my ass and then he takes a swig
of beer like he's never drank a beer
before
in his [__] life
just after months and months and months
of them and telling us what beer we can
and can't drink because it'll make you
gay
does it make any sense no because they
don't make any sense it doesn't it's not
supposed to make sense
they're just they just want to propagate
hate
and that's what Tucker Carlson is doing
here
he's propagating that Obama is gay
and that is egregious enough
to what to not elect Joe Biden to not
elect Democrats because
the Democratic party welcomes the lgbtq
community into their coalition
so somehow I don't I don't unders I mean
I don't understand it really honestly
I again want them to keep going
keep stepping on these rakes that would
be awesome because it provides us tons
of content but also a national narrative
and don't forget to subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast for that
mocking of these idiots because that's
what we're gonna do a lot today
is Mark Tucker Carlson and Tim Poole
it's gonna be fun
oh it's gonna be fun today
here on the Tony Michaels podcast I got
a lot to show you I want to thank a few
people as everyone knows on Wednesday
nights I go sing karaoke
at a local karaoke bar here
and several people uh bought me shots
last night and I have videos and some
pictures that I'm gonna make something
later on to thank you guys but I want to
say thank you to some of the folks who
actually bought me shots and if you want
to buy a shot now I actually bought some
of those shots you can go to subscribe
to at the Tony michaels.com at the very
top you say bye actually you know I
gotta refresh this because we changed
this see here see Tucker Carlson is here
at the top and then you can buy buy me a
shot but I'm gonna thank a few people
for buying a shot off the Tony
michaels.com I think there was five
folks
who bought shots that's if I look a
little hmm today that's
thanks to you
so thank you Renee Let's see we got
Renee Gary
I also have uh Connie
Robin
and Maria and I bought some shots so
thank you very much I'll put out I'll
probably put that uh
that video on Discord so you guys can go
over to the Discord and you can see the
the thank you video you can actually
watch me do some of those shots that you
guys bought for me and Discord is where
the chat party never stops
it's crazy over there
like I always say they need Jesus some
people have been saying in the chapter
like I'm tired of hearing about Discord
so go join it then
[Laughter]
I'm tired of hearing about it why can't
the problem is I can't bring up like the
Discord chat on the screen it doesn't
work that way
at this point at least I hope maybe we
can eventually but right now
um Big Stuff says Tony alcohol is not
good for you yeah it isn't but you know
you gotta you gotta make compromises in
life you got to make compromises in life
and that's one of my compromises is uh
have fun a couple times a week maybe
once twice a week so I wanna I wanna
thank everyone for those and if you want
to go see the um it'll probably be later
today or tomorrow that I get the video
up of Mia doing the shots but if you
want to if you want to get on the action
and get a thank you uh just and go to
the attorney michaels.com you can buy me
a shot last night I took advantage of
those shots
I want so thank you very much thank you
very much for everyone who um who
participated in buying Tony a shot
continue to do that it's it's a great
way to support the show because you know
we get to have fun we joke around you
guys know I like Jagermeister you guys
continually would say you wanted to buy
me a shot in the chat so I'm like well
why don't we just put a button to where
you can why not you want to buy me one
let's do it that's fine by me
uh so we put the button up and it helps
support the show obviously I'm not going
to take every single one Jesus Christ I
would never be able to do the show but
it is to support the show it's to
support me staying on the air so I
appreciate it I I I'm I'm totally funded
from you guys the audience I don't have
any affiliation anywhere I'm not paid by
someone to do this
um it is you guys as you the listeners
who come here and and fund Independent
Media like this not just not just with
money
but it's also important to share it and
be here and engage that's that's
important too that's that's super
important uh how else am I going to be
able to make a thumbnail that says is
Tucker gay no one would let me make that
besides me right besides you I'm gonna
get a ton of hate comments for Libby's
they're like oh Tony you're being
homophobic well come watch the show and
you'll know that I'm using his tactic on
the thumbnail
that's what happened
and again I don't understand why why the
right wing all of a sudden thinks that
this is a great way uh to to win the
election
for Donald Trump I don't know if they're
trying to get the anti-gay vote you know
all feverish about Obama
being gay but here's the thing folks
really honestly if you think about it
all the people who would watch this who
would go yeah I think that's true
already believe that Obama's gay as if
it [__] matters like they believe all
kinds of wild [__] too honestly they
believe all kinds of wild [__] wild [__]
even past that Obama might be gay
as if again
I can't even believe I'm saying this
what the [__] does it matter I I mean
we're gonna hey
you [__] right-wing incels we're
gonna have our first gay president at
some point it's gonna happen
just hang in there for a little bit all
right we're gonna have one and they're
probably gonna be a damn good president
just because they have an American
experience that no other former
president has ever had
in the White House okay so if Barack
Obama is gay
or was or whatever I I don't know
then his experience led him to be a
decent [__] president unlike your guy
who's a [__] chucklehead of buffoon
and a [__] fraud okay and a criminal
and taboo
I mean just because just because Obama
may or may not had had gay relationships
in the 1990s
he hey you know what he's not he's not
charged with 91 [__] felonies he's
not charged under the Espionage Act he's
not he's not a [__] spy
he's not charged with with basic
Insurrection obstructing official
proceedings oh man he's not there he's
not he's not charged in with felony
business fraud in New York
he's not charged with election
interference and Rico charges in Georgia
so I mean you know I'll take I'll take
the guy who used to be gay in the 90s
who is already the president for two
[__] terms who can't be a [__]
president anymore yeah I'll take sure
whatever fine [__] what
listen if you're looking for it to make
sense of why they're doing this you're
you're missing it it's not supposed to
make sense it's just supposed to be hate
propaganda
they know they they know they know their
audience hates Barack Obama because he's
black he's the scary black man remember
oh scary black man he's a scary black
man who used to be president who hasn't
been president for almost eight goddamn
years
but now they're like oh yeah he's
totally gay because they got this whole
thing where and then I don't know if you
know this but they got this whole thing
where Michelle Obama is a is a man right
and it's hard to sell that one oh man
they work they work feverishly to try to
sell that Michelle Obama used to be a
man as if that [__] matters
what the [__] does that matter who gives
a [__] they do because it's hate
propaganda
their goal is to just feed that [__]
hate propaganda to these [__] incels
that's the whole point
period
their point isn't to win
their point isn't to gain power and
that's the good news folks
that's the good news they're losing
badly
when this is the best they got Tucker
Carlson is supposed to be the best
propagandist they've ever had in the
history of ever on the right wing
and he let some fraud on his show who
has been who claims have been dunked
been debunked time and time and time
again about this 1999 uh encounter he
had with Obama
this guy is not credible whatsoever not
even close to being credible even if the
story is true it's hard to believe it
just from this guy's past
like even if the story were true which I
don't give a [__] if it is honestly if
Barack Obama was doing a little Coke and
smoking a little crack he's kind of up
there with Hunter Biden and coolness
right
Jesus Christ they like [__] Ted
Nugent and Kid Rock
the Grandpa's of meth why what do you
want from me
and they're they're saying it's bad that
Barack Obama had snort a little Coke did
tried a little crack
and had sex what okay what I still don't
understand how this is a problem
everyone says they're still laughing
uh Regina says I don't read Facebook do
you mean like the comments in Facebook
or Facebook in general because I do not
read Facebook but I do read through
comments the problem is uh and I gotten
this comment a lot here lately and
people wanting me to address certain
issues and I might I might not I don't
know I just got two hours to to run with
here so it's it's a little difficult and
you know what our new schedule things
are changing which is good we got great
things coming the show is expanding and
gonna be expanding rapidly and we're
gonna go with the flow so if we need
more time we'll take more time
just to give you a Lowdown on Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Thursdays I'm going to be
doing the show and throw into Gabe
Sanchez's what was that live he's going
to do a full hour for you on the stories
that he can't get to with a what was
that and break them down kind of in that
style
but just live kind of like what we do
here on the air
so we're going to be throwing to him
three days a week Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so you get three hours that day
if you'd like to have three hours on
Monday and Friday come over to
patreon.com
you're going to be able to sign up for
the 20 tier and you guys are going to be
able to get a pre-game hour I'm not sure
what we're gonna call it it's just like
an hour before when I'm prepping it's
kind of like a producer's corner we'll
be going through stories on Monday and
Friday to figure out what what I missed
this week what are we gonna talk about
this week what happened over the weekend
on Monday and then on Friday mornings
we'll go through what happened during
the week so we can find those stories
that you guys want to see on the show so
I'm going to bring you in that first
hour on prep and we might keep doing it
more days a week and it's possible that
Gabe Sanchez is going to need more time
he might have to do more days a week but
right now the schedule is on Monday you
can go to
patreon.comichels you can get the
pre-hour this show will always be free
free two hours and then on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday you'll get Gabe
Sanchez an hour after this show and then
on Friday you're gonna have the hour
before and you'll have this show with
bonehead of the week at the end of the
Tony Michaels podcast as always
finishing off your week with me and Gabe
so it's it's gonna be it's gonna be a
great time
and there's gonna be a lot to get to
a ton to get to
and we're gonna have and we're gonna
have fun doing it we're gonna have fun
we're gonna mock them we're gonna yell
and scream we're gonna rant
a lot of people saying Tony do you read
comments I read a lot of comments I
don't read all of them
because like when I get comments because
we broadcast to Facebook YouTube the
upwire YouTube uh we broadcast to Twitch
um there's a lot there's and we have
Discord and there's several channels in
Discord so I got a lot of stuff that I
got to go through
I got a lot of DMS so if I if you DM me
or something or you're sending a comment
it's not that I'm I'm ignoring it I
might be but I I can't read every single
one of them and respond to every single
one I know it would be cool if I could
but I mean I I wouldn't be able to do
the show because I'd be responding all
the time so it's not that I'm ignoring I
promise intentionally and sometimes
but I mean you know when trolls come in
and they say stupid [__] what are you
supposed to do they ignore them
so ready
what day is it oh it's Thursday we're
getting to the end of the week
we're getting to the end of the week
it's Thursday September 7th we're going
to get to uh Friday tomorrow we're going
to bonan of the week so don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
right here on YouTube you're going to be
able to vote vote vote vote for bonehead
of the week and you know what we should
do we should put a poll on YouTube
because we put the bonehead poll on
YouTube
we should see if we should pull the poll
off Twitter because we've been putting
the poll on Twitter that's how it
started but at Twitter's such a [__] box
now and it doesn't seem like anyone's
really willing to engage over there he
has so many goddamn anti-semites and
Nazis and bigots and fragile white men
talking about how [__]
Obama's gay as if it matters it's weird
stuff
so I'm thinking we might we might put
the poll over on Discord it is possible
that we'll start doing that we'll just
put it over on Discord and then we'll
put it on YouTube and for you guys to
vote there we'll take it down off
Twitter because it just doesn't end and
[__] Twitter you know I mean and I said
go over to the Discord make sure you're
getting in the Discord chat no forget
that
don't forget to go join the Discord and
again I know that some people was uh
they were like
I don't like Discord
no that's not the one I wanted God damn
it
uh some people are like I don't like
Discord when you don't have to like it
and you don't have to go over there if
you don't want but if you do want to get
in on the action because it's wild over
there make sure make sure you do this
make sure you uh verify when you go into
the Discord server so we know that
you're a human and they'll take care of
us real easy you just go to the Welcome
Center there's a little tab that says
welcome center just click on that it
gives you the directions you just got to
hit the the check mark button just one
button they'll get you verified and that
way you guys can get down in the live
show chat you guys can see the doubt me
step you can see the hot takes
um you can go you can go look at other
people's stuff that they've made
pictures that they've taken memes
there's a whole collection of political
memes over there if you're looking to uh
if you're looking to propagate the
internet with memes
our Discord server is the place to do it
now also you can get in on the venmo
chat you guys know you can send me a
venmo chat venmo Super Chat as I call it
on the Tony michaels.com let me show you
here you can go to thetonymichaels.com
and at the very top there's the uh
there's the episode the current episode
there's buy Tony a shot but here's the
venmo super chat if you send me a a
message with your venmo Super Chat I'll
bring it up on the air I promise I'll
bring it up on the air uh Erica
actually yeah sent to
a
a message here
so let me bring that one up on the air
it's a venmo chat venmo chat here
it takes me a second because it's like a
roundabout way that I have to do it it's
a roundaboutly but it works here it is
uh Tony I always look forward to your
show love your rants thanks
boom thank you very very much for the
venmo super chat again if you want to
get in on the venmo Super Chat
you just go to the attorney michaels.com
you just go to the very top venmo Super
Chat is there also if you want to join
the patreon to get in on the hour before
show on Mondays and Fridays just hit the
support Tony on patreon you go you go
over there it'll be in the 20 tier is
where it's going to be this weekend so
that's how that's the threshold and it's
going to be pretty strict now the Sunday
rants will still do the Sunday Rants and
stuff on patreon uh and and I'm gonna
make them public sometime and hey if
you're a patreon member you're you're
being there you'll be in those but the
hour before that will be us the the
group of people twenty dollars and above
uh on patreon so go to patreon.com D
Tony Michaels get in on that and make
sure make sure when you go to the Tony
michaels.com the other thing that you're
doing is you're going down past the
podcast links and you see uh Gabe's
YouTube channel here make sure you're
subscribing to Gabe's YouTube channel
you're not going to want to You're Not
Gonna Wanna Miss that because that's how
we're gonna throw to Gabe uh every
single Tuesday Wednesday Thursday it's
going to go to his channel it's not
going to be on this channel be on his
channel but it automatically do it so if
you're on YouTube and you're watching
this show it'll automatically go to
Gabe's Channel
automatically boom just like that so
make sure you're going to the Tony
michaels.com and you're following Gabe
Sanchez's uh Channel and look at all the
links there at the Tony michaels.com
considering supporting the show that's
what keeps me live on the air speaking
of that we got to take a quick quick
break when we come back we'll still be
live because of you and your support now
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
oh we got a birthday in the chat art I
happy birthday happy birthday
to you
[Music]
chat being part of the [__] fam here
any other birthdays try to get him in
the chat if I notice them and see him or
someone Point them out to me I'll I'll
give you a birthday message too no
problem
no problem
um some people want to see the graphic
for the schedule here it is you know
what I think I'm gonna post this on the
um on the Community page dude so you
guys can find it this is this will be
the new schedule so Mondays you'll have
the patreon only pre-hour with me it's
kind of like a producer's corner I don't
know what we're gonna call it yet I
haven't decided
um exactly what we're gonna call it and
maybe we'll uh the audience can help out
in that uh in that pre-hour so to be a
pre-hour with me on Mondays and Fridays
and then the show you know the two-hour
show the Tony Michaels podcast as always
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
and then we have
the Gabe Sanchez what was that live
coming to you directly after the show on
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays oh
Thursday
so so if in the next week let's say
you're like we're time traveling and
this is Thursday and next week if you're
watching this show on YouTube you'll
automatically be
cut to Gabe Sanchez's show what was that
live
that's what he's calling you what was
that live I haven't again I haven't
decided the uh what we're gonna call the
pre-hour
I don't know if you guys got ideas uh go
to patreon send me some ideas in the DM
or go to Discord and do that you know
let me know what you guys think for a
name for the pre-hour uh the producer's
corner or something like that we're just
gonna go through the news stories it's
basically going to be you guys and me
prepping for the show I'm going to show
you kind of like behind the scenes how
it works what I'm doing
and how how I get to the uh the
commentary that I have
and it'll be interesting on Thursday on
Friday morning because I still will you
know have the Wednesday
and now I I don't know if I have a
really good weekend Monday might be
interesting too here's what I've been
doing to prep for this
I'm gonna have to get my ass out of bed
an hour early every day yeah that's
right it's not it's not exciting for me
because I'm kind of a night owl if you
want to know the honest truth
um so I've been having to get it I'm
trying to train myself to get out of bed
like an hour early
and that way that way I I can get to the
mic an hour early on Mondays and Fridays
that's what I gotta do listen I know
myself I need coffee sometimes I need my
my morning walk to really get my [__]
going
I need that I need that stuff sometimes
to really uh um
be prepared to come here and talk to you
there's been a few times where I barely
made it to the microphone I don't know
if you guys remember back in March after
my birthday holy [__]
I was so still trashed when I when I
opened the mic that morning it was a
Thursday morning because it was a
Wednesday when I celebrated my birthday
with all the with all the karaoke group
that we have
and oh man I thought I was gonna be able
to do it but I got there on time I did
the show Full two hours boom got it done
but my prep my prep
to be able to do this extra hours to get
up an hour early which is good I need I
probably need that
in my life I need to be going to bed an
hour early and get up an hour early and
if that's what it means but we're gonna
have fun I think I think that the
pre-show is gonna be
um very excellent I think we're gonna
get to know each other more it'll be a
smaller group which is kind of nice so
we get to know each other more
um I I'm not opposed to inviting some of
you guys on camera at that you know to
some of those things
uh we'll we'll figure that out what that
what that is exactly going to entail and
how it'll work uh but I think it's going
to be really good the other thing we're
going to do different
um is that that will be on a different
Channel because it's like a members only
so it'd be the patreon only Channel I'm
going to open up a YouTube channel with
just patreon stuff and then also the
Roundtable democracy I plan on doing one
tomorrow that that's when I want to do
it uh we might do it this afternoon but
I really want to do it tomorrow it gives
me more time uh to do it but we want to
do one on ballotpedia uh me and my
mighty librarian have talked about
bellapedia in several of the round
tables uh democracy and the 10 minute
tips so we're probably going to do a 10
minute tip tomorrow uh on ballot PD and
show you what that is sounds interesting
doesn't it ballot pedia so we're going
to do that but here's the thing also
we're going to open up our its own
YouTube channel for the library of
democracy I believe but that's where all
the round tables are going to be the 10
minute tips and everything are going to
be on a YouTube channel uh in and of
itself so it's not like commingling you
guys can have so so that's all the
expansion that is happening here and
it's very exciting all this stuff is
expanding and going in different
directions we have a great team working
with us all the mods
um and speaking of that here over the
weekend I'm gonna get a form on the
internet there's going to be a link on
the website
and I'll guide you to it once we get it
live we're gonna be we're going to be
taking names of people who who possibly
want to be moderators uh and we're going
to do it with a Google form so you're
going to go to this form and and fill it
out if you have interest that way we
have a list of people
um for potential moderators if you guys
want to be moderators and we're changing
a little bit about the process about
being a moderator and that sort of thing
so I'm going to make a form if you guys
want to be moderators and you guys can
always you know just sign up whenever
you want and then we'll go through those
and when we need a moderator for a
certain uh platform because that's one
thing that the moderate you know that
you have to be on different platforms
and some people aren't like on Facebook
I am not on Facebook some people don't
like twitch
you know so yeah we're going to get a
form out there and uh so there's gonna
be a a quite a bit of expansion here uh
in the [__] fam universe as what
we're going to be doing so so stay tuned
don't don't go anywhere when we're
talking about those changes in those
expansions let's see if we can get Gabe
Sanchez he's over there in the Discord
chat [__] around yeah Gabe's over
there talking he should be getting on
the show but he's over there [__]
around on Discord
no he is really
um you'll see me in a game appear in
Discord every once in a while and that's
why you should go join the Discord
server it's on the Tony michaels.com
just go click that join the Discord
server and make sure you verify follow
the twitch channel it's free to follow
on Twitch and if you want to subscribe
link your Amazon Prime account with your
Twitch account and that's subscription's
free and then also follow Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel you're gonna need these
links you're gonna need these things now
so don't forget to do any of that oh by
the way and I've been bugging Gabe
Sanchez if he's listening
he might be I don't know maybe he isn't
he isn't he isn't in the green room yet
um but he's been jacking around over
there on uh on Discord this morning but
if he's listening I've been telling him
to get me a slide for the pardon blanket
did you guys know that you could buy a
pardon blanket that thing is real now
it's real
the the pardon blanket is real
see you can go you can go buy your own
pardon blanket what you do is the
easiest way again is just go to the
attorney michaels.com roll down to Gabe
Sanchez merch that'll take you to this
link tree and then you can go to his
merch store and get you a pardon blanket
he you know what you should do too you
always should bug him to do
and we should put we should have him put
the pardon blanket button on his link
tree so you can give right to the pardon
blanket boom just like that so many
people wanted a pardon blanket for so
long they're like is that thing real
and it's real it's real now like it was
an idea and it was fake and it's just a
silly little commercial but it's a real
map let's see can we
see if we can get the Gabe where are you
where are you Gabe Sanchez I know you're
there
I know he wants to talk about the Decker
Carlson that's why I'm waiting just a
bit uh for him but let me pull up uh Tim
pull here while he's because it's not
just about Tucker right Tucker's trying
to
Tucker Tucker Carlson in this attempt to
paint Obama as gay
um all he's really trying to do is
is uh you know spread hate propaganda
and of course you know people like Tim
Poole even if it's fake even if it's not
real I mean they love the spread the
hate propaganda they they love them some
hate propaganda now here's Tim Poole on
his show I don't know what what is he
what is is it called Tim cast
oh my God this [__] idiot and here's
Temple you know this guy always wears a
beanie hat you know
and I think I know why it is I don't you
know supposedly this guy makes a lot of
money if he wanted gender reaffirming
surgery he could look it doesn't make
you trans Tim to go get hair implants
right
just because you get gender reconfirming
surgery doesn't mean that you're
that you're trans Tim you can go fix
that thing if you want and stop wearing
them stupid [__] beanies
like literally you just you can go have
the surgery done he plugs in I don't I
mean I've got a nice you know you see
that's all match around right there you
see that here baby that's all match
around Tim
I don't know if you can grow here like
that buddy maybe you can't but that's
there's something wrong with that Tim
there's nothing wrong with not being
able to grow a [__] sexy head of hair
like this
it doesn't make you any less of a man
it's not your hair that makes you less
of a man it's really your attitude
right it's your attitude that [__]
does that
and the beanie the beanie look
beanies are okay I'm okay with people
wearing beanies but when you won't wear
a beanie because you're scared that
someone might see that you have a very
receding hairline and you're not willing
you got the money
you have to time Tim
to go get the gender reconfirming
surgery right
you got the you got it you got the time
and the money the resources man you
should go it's not it doesn't mean that
you're trans to get gender reconfirming
so I mean guys do it all the time
you know what's his name Stephen Crowder
had his had his tennis tits done hi his
chest he had his chest reconstructed you
know
make him look more manly I guess gender
reconfirming surgery Elon Musk had
earplugs put in Tim your [__] dude
elon's your guy Tim he's your guy he's
your boy
it's okay Tim
Elon did it Elon got Jenna reconfirming
surgery
on his head
and there's something wrong with it
there's nothing right there and it
doesn't even it doesn't even put him in
the category of trans which I know you
hate trans people I know you would just
like for them to be off the face of the
Earth and I understand that your
audience thinks that they just started
existing a few years ago
because you say stupid [__] hateful [__]
about you know our countrymen the lgbtq
community people who are who are [__]
Patriots people who are Americans our
neighbors our community members you say
bile [__] about them so I understand why
it's confusing
that you would you know not want to get
hair plugs in this effort to
pretend to be hateful but listen listen
and if you think I'm full of [__] about
the [__] about the hair plug thing
and him him being like whoa whoa whoa
you can't accuse me of getting gender
re-confirming surgery
that's what he [__] thinks
[__] prove me wrong
Tim prove me wrong that's the reason why
you want that you wear a [__] beanie
all the time because you're because you
don't think you think bald heads doesn't
make you manly and you're not willing to
go get the the process done because
someone's gonna accuse you of having
gender re-concern confirming surgery
you [__] you [__] weak piece of
[__]
and if you don't believe that that's the
truth Listen to How what his [__]
logic here is for Tucker Carlson
on this dumb [__] interview about
these false accusations against Obama as
if Obama being gay somehow is [__]
controversial listen legitimate
political reason well let me slow down
there's no legitimate factual reason to
interview a con artist and crackhead
who's making these absurd claims oh oh
okay all right all right okay so
we agree Tim is that what you're saying
probably not let's listen I'm not a fan
of this I wasn't a fan of it when they
did it to Brett Kavanaugh I'm not a fan
of it now he's not a fan of it because
he actually didn't get the interview
Tucker did that's why he's not a fan of
it
let's be clear on that
Tim Poole does not give us does not give
a [__]
about rather this is lies or not this
guy propagates lies every [__] day of
the week all the time against the lgbtq
community every [__] day
all the time and this narrative is right
in his [__] wheelhouse hate
propaganda is right in 10 pools [__]
wheelhouse okay
so he's really the the reason why he
doesn't think this is a good idea
because Tim Poole didn't have the idea
that's why he thinks that because Tucker
got the [__] interview and got all
the views on Twitter and all the [__]
accolades from all the the Twitter incel
Army not him
but listen to what he says about what he
thinks about the thing that he says is
really stupid that being said I applaud
Tucker Carlson for doing it oh
you do you do
I'm not racist but it's the same [__]
same [__] [__]
I'm not racist but
these are all wise and it's all [__]
and I'm jealous that Tucker got the
interview not me to produce the hate
propaganda that's gonna be pumped out on
the Internet it's gonna get uh Tucker
Carlson another another round of the
incel army loving him to death which I
really want as Tim Poole
a bald man who's scared to be bald
because it makes me feel less manly
I wanted the accolades but since Tucker
gets them I still want to spread the
hate propaganda which the was the
intention of Tucker Carlson in the first
place is to get these [__] idiots and
these these these in-cell hate
propaganda foot soldiers to continue to
press
the the policies of Nazis against the
lgbtq community because that's really at
the heart of it right here right now
is that they're excited about this
narrative not because it hurts Democrats
not because Americans are they're going
to move the needle because Obama
was accused of being gay
it's not going to move the needle at all
but they're trying to do
is to trying to make sure that the Nazis
have [__] to talk about
if you think
that these Nazis that showed up at
Disney World
and these ones that showed up on an
overpass pass in Florida the same ones
that went to a drag show in Ohio and
were screaming Republican policy points
at people
in out of a bullhorn
if you think if you think for a second
that this kind of [__] sludge about
Barack Obama being gay and this Tucker
Carlson every isn't going to end up on
one of them Pro protest signs down at
the Nazi rally at Disney World just hang
tight
that's who they're talking to right now
again I'm Mark Tucker and I'm mocking
Tim pool but at the heart of this what
they're doing
is they're creating hate propaganda for
people to light-footedly believe and and
follow Nazis
that's what this is oh Tony Jesus Christ
that's crazy you can't you can't go that
way yes this is exactly what it is
every [__] time this is their
playbook why do you think Ron DeSantis
doesn't denounce his supporters that are
carrying Nazi Flags
and Howling Hitler
and and and and saying to to unjail Adam
wapping for for trying to destroy a
power grid domestic terrorism
they love they love them some [__]
some insurrectionist by the way
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
that's what this is
this is deployment of Nazi propaganda
hate propaganda to their little [__]
foot soldiers look at Tim Poole's face
here he's mad that he's not the one that
got this [__] interview that it was
Tucker
but even in the same universe as that he
knows what the what the [__]
interview means and he knows what this
information needs to be used for and how
to deploy it
it's [__] hate propaganda
and again they're gonna talk about it
for [__] weeks and eventually it's
gonna be picked up by Fox News on
Newsmax probably by the night
if it hasn't already appeared on there
and by the end of the week and the
weekend they'll be [__] they'll be
[__] real journalists out there
asking questions to real [__] serious
politicians about what they thought
about Barack Obama being gay in 1999
you see how this [__] works
I've been trying to yell and scream it
for [__] ever that I understand how
the right wing forms their narratives
and if you understand how the right wing
does it and it works I it [__] works
propaganda works that's why it's
propaganda
okay
and if you're not willing to fight
propaganda in the in the arena that
propaganda fights then you're gonna lose
and standing back and going oh my God
this is [__]
now this is just a joke
this is just a no it's hate propaganda
it's designed
to form hate against the lgbtq community
because they know the people who are
willing to commit hate crimes
and the people who are willing to pass
legislation
to try to get rid of a certain group of
people our countrymen
and women
and folks in this country
they want they want to eradicate them
with policies
with legislation
that's what this is about it ain't about
a Barack Obama they just know Tucker
Carlson and the right wing hate
propaganda arm knows
that the people who [__] hate Barack
Obama because he was the first black
president are the same ones that are
willing to [__] hate gay people
and they gotta keep the fear going what
do you think the [__] Bud Light thing
was about
it ain't nothing to do with the beer
[__] kid rock is still drinking Bud
Light
it had to do with the hate propaganda
against the lgbtq community because let
me tell you something
their target is trans people the lgbtq
community and women and the reason why
is because if they can keep targeting
them and make ground
and taking away their rights
they just they just may be able to come
after everyone's rights
they just may
I mean I I'll give you an example later
on in the show this Tommy tuberville
[__] about abortion tied to military
promotions which is really [__] crazy
it makes no sense at all it's not
supposed to make sense though
what they're saying is is they don't
want people to be able to cross state
lines
they don't want people to be able to
cross state lines and they're saying it
out loud
they don't want people to cross state
lines to receive Health Care
they don't want it
and that's what they're talking about
I'll show it to you in Mike Pence's
rhetoric about it
because they always say the opposite and
they're always projecting what they
[__] mean just like Tim Poole here
listen to this [__] about this Obama
being gay Tucker Carlson interview you
know why
welcome to the Tit for Tat world of
politics so to clarify there's a
political reason to do this to attack
the Democrats I guess to make them look
like degenerates to strike at The
credibility of the Obamas maybe to
prevent Michelle Obama from Gaining
traction or to create just some negative
press around the Obamas fine whatever
okay so first off again he's projecting
that they're terrified they're terrified
of Michelle Obama
of the popularity of Michelle Obama he's
projecting that hard
terrified of it and this goes into the
stupid [__] narrative that Barack
Obama gay so that means Michelle Obama
must be a man type [__] as if any of
that any of that matters even if it were
true which it's not
at least that I know
and who gives a [__] about it anyways
they're terrified of Michelle Obama
and the reason why is because Barack
Obama can't be president again he can't
be won't be
she could be they're terrified of it oh
my God they hate that she's popular I
[__] hate it but let's continue let's
see what other hate he has because we
know that's why he hates Michelle Obama
she's a black woman and they love the
color of man that's why they that's why
they [__] hate her
simply put
the Democrats yeah the left and the
media in this country yeah okay okay you
got my attention Tim let's let's hear it
buddy entertained the most psychotic
lies you could imagine about Brett
Kavanaugh
Tucker Carlson is simply engaging in the
exact same behavior
oh that's that's great that's great Tim
oh man you're you're you're spot on
you're spot on because um because Barack
Obama is the one that's seeking to be a
Supreme Court Justice you know he's he's
definitely seeking that maybe maybe
that's what they're trying to fend off
as Maybe Barack because I'm not opposed
to that folks oh [__] let me tell you
something if there's a Democratic
president and I I know that you know the
next choice of the Supreme Court most
people want another woman of color right
but really honestly
man I'm just saying for the sake of uh
you know owning owning the owning the
chuds because I love to own the chuds
that's great we should do a little bit
of that
on the chuds here really honestly Barack
Obama being a supreme court nominee
that'd be like cherry on the top
of my mocking cake wouldn't it maybe
that's what they're trying to fend off
they're terrified that
that Barack Obama could be a supreme
court nominee and that uh Michelle
Obama's could be the president United
States easy hands down which I don't
think any of that's really that possible
Right
I mean why would Barack Obama want to be
a Supreme Court Justice maybe he does
and Michelle Obama has said time and
time again no [__] way never gonna
run for president hated that [__] not
gonna do it I supported my husband but
I'm not going to do that [__] myself so
I mean I don't understand why they're so
terrified but this is hate propaganda
so it's not supposed to make sense
it's not supposed to make sense
to you who have brain cells to rub
together but think about think about the
hate masturbating uh in cell white
fragile in cells that are in your
comment section every once in a while
do they make sense when they type in
[__] oh God I get them all the time they
[__] don't make sometimes I can't
even understand what the hell they're
saying I'm like I know you hate me
and I know you're trying to say
something of why you hate me
and you know most of the time they're
trying to like call you gay and [__]
but it's it I don't understand half the
time what they're mad about it doesn't
make any sense to me
but again it's not supposed to make
sense folks it's just pure-blooded hate
because they're trying to build an army
of hate
and use information to do it hate
propaganda
oh boy okay so let's um
now let's see
um I thought I had oh yeah here here's
some hate propaganda for you at work in
the United States Senate of all places
Tommy tuberville
uh Tommy uh two branches did you know
when he was first elected Tommy
tuberville couldn't name the three
branches of government
it was like all the branches of
government he's like yeah
and the the Congress and and there's the
there's the president branch and then
there's the uh hmm there's guy I think
there's four maybe two branches of
government he's such a [__] fool why
did anyone think just because he he won
a national championship with Auburn
makes him qualified to be a politician
what the [__] is this [__]
are you [__] kidding me
this guy's dumber than a box of rocks no
wonder they picked him and to use him in
this effort to act like that it's
abortion is the reason why he's holding
up military promotions
he's like oh they're they're writing
poems on on battleships what what do you
mean they're writing poems on bets so
what the [__] are you talking about man
these people are serving our country you
people for years have claimed that the
veterans are yours we had we had Fred
Wellman on
on Tuesday
and me and Fred were talking and if you
haven't seen any go back and launch it
but me and Fred were talking a lot about
this idea that just because you're in
the military makes you qualified to be a
politician or you know teacher or
anything like that that she's not
necessarily true I mean you know we
should definitely definitely
be proud of the people who serve for our
country
but I mean like Fred Wellman said
Timothy McVeigh was a veteran
I mean come on folks it's not just
because you serve in our military
doesn't make you flawless
it certainly doesn't we're all human
I mean Timothy McVeigh
maybe not as much of a human as some of
us but
he still was but Tommy tuber real
doesn't seem to understand this
but this all boils down to the ability
of someone to go to another state and
receive Health Care specifically a woman
remember that specifically a woman but
here is uh here's Tommy two branches
um trying to explain this to us I'm
disappointed that a secretary would say
that about a senator uh and he's sitting
this very office uh when he was uh going
up for confirmation of himself and and
uh you know just makes you feel bad that
we got leaders in the country like that
but you know what what makes me feel bad
Tommy Tommy two branches is what makes
me feel bad is we got a United States
senator in Alabama
who thinks he's really smart and he's
not so [__] smart
that he is trying to make sure to hold
up an entire National Security apparatus
for promotions which has never been an
issue because he wants to say the word
abortion on the news because that's
literally that's literally what Tommy
tuberville is doing he's just going on
the news and saying the reason why he's
doing this because of abortion which
that's not and has nothing to do with it
nothing to do with it at all at all
but there's something more Sinister
Brewing here okay it's not just the
military promotion it's not just the
abortion there's something more Sinister
Brewing here I'll show you I'll show you
another clip-end for this one watch this
because uh as I just told you if I
thought it was hurting Readiness I
wouldn't be doing this [__] it's
concerning it is that you got people
that that are in Secretary positions
like that that would say something like
that in our country uh instead of
getting on the phone and calling me you
know they don't have to give you a phone
call [__]
there you are not entitled to phone
calls from secretaries and navies or
Secretary of the Air Force or Pentagon
in general [__]
and frankly it is disappointing that we
have people like you defending white
nationalist in the military acting like
acting like people who are breaking
their oath to their country
as being white nationalist and being
against the Constitution
to protect all people and freedom and
follow their [__] oath
that you would you would be like ah
there's no white nationalist I call them
patriots he calls White nationalists
Patriots this [__] guy but let me
show you something more Sinister Brewing
about this issue in the Republican party
because it's not it's not just Tommy
tuberville
it's not just him now here it is here's
the video this is Mike Pence of course
Mike Pence is pretending that he's gonna
run for president you know what I mean
is this guy still is he still pretending
that he's running for president I guess
so I don't know but he was on he was on
some uh news or excuse me radio show
and he's and they ask him
about the tuberville blockade of the
military promotions
because of paid time off right so this
is what this is all about
Tommy tube reveal and the Republicans
don't like that women in the military
take paid time off because they the
state that they're stationed in that
they don't choose they don't choose what
[__] station state they're stationed
in just so happened the military might
put them in a red state with a bunch of
[__] fascists who took away their
rights to Health Care
are trying to take away their [__]
and they're saying that she is not able
to take paid leave to make sure to go to
a [__] state where she can receive
Health Care
because it's banned in the fascist state
that she's stationed in right you know
what maybe Marjorie Taylor Green's
National voice isn't such a [__] bad
idea then we can move these military
bases out of these [__] red States
and don't give them the economic power
that comes with having a military base I
don't know maybe that's a consideration
you know maybe she's on to something who
knows
but that's what it's about it ain't
about it ain't about the word abortion
because that's what we need to stop
doing
our narrative it's health care it's
women's health care it's not [__]
abortion that's not what they're talking
about they're not talking about that
they're talking about giving because
they don't what they really don't want
is two things okay and this is the more
Sinister thing that's underlying here
they don't want women in the military
okay
that's what that's that's the main
course of action here they don't want
women in the military because honestly
frankly you know what if you don't have
women in the military you don't have to
worry you don't have to worry about the
government paying for Women's Health
Care
in that kind of convenient for them
yeah that's kind of that's kind of rad
isn't it
we don't have women in the military want
to be paying federal dollars for Women's
Health Care
but the other thing that is more
Sinister here and Mike Pence projects it
in this interview let me show it to you
because everything with these
[__] is projection
and you can't you can't convince me of
anything different but listen to what
Mike Pence says in this
let's listen to the little detail where
he talks about the freedom to travel
listen to this yeah well what I would
say if I was uh if I was working in
Washington DC as I look across the
Potomac at the Pentagon I would say this
can all be over tomorrow if you just
stop undermining a state pro-life laws I
mean look oh undermining State Pro
LifeLock see here's the problem Mike
here's the problem is the Pentagon the
Pentagon is a federal their Federal
[__] agencies we we have a we have a
federal government who has a military
Mike you [__]
and you are passing state laws to get
rid of people's rights
and some of those people in those states
don't have a choice where they're
stationed in your [__] states that
are oppressive and trying to ban Women's
Health Care okay these women are not
asking you to pay for their procedures
they want you to stop oppressing them in
the [__] States
is what they want and that's what we
should get to here is the obvious thing
is to codify Roe v Wade to make sure
these [__] red States can't tell
women what health care they can and
cannot get
because that's what it is it's [__]
health care but listen to this part as
Gabe Sanchez joins us here listen to
this part Gabe about travel listen to
what he says listen if you can hear the
projection for Mike Pence because I
think this is you know they don't want
women in the military that's what this
whole narrative is about they don't want
women in America but listen to what he
says about the freedom to travel here
see if you can catch the projection it's
wild stuff and when I heard I was like
holy [__] that's what the hell they want
we don't we don't need the Pentagon
under the Biden Administration working
to end run Provide support for people to
uh to essentially travel across state
lines for abortions people it's a free
country people can go where they want to
go they can take leave in the military
and go where they want but I okay I
don't support taxpayer funding of
abortion and I don't support the
pentagon's efforts to subsidize and
provide and facilitate abortions in a
way that undermines the laws of the
jurisdictions in which our basis are
established and operate so all that all
that can be over tomorrow if the
Pentagon would just stand down on the
attempting to push a liberal social
agenda it's not liberal social they're
just saying they can take leave to
travel
it's not even that it's it's a
it's a right to having Health Care
right well again it's not anything more
complicated than you know Republicans
getting uh they're [__] panties in a
[__] wedge and and complaining that
they're not able are you saying Mike
Pence wears panties 100
Mike Pence wears a pair of panties do
you think Tommy duberville wears panties
uh I think Tommy touver aware is a
little like mankini oh really okay you
think it's like an Auburn one because
he's always running he's always like I
mean I I have to I have to know how did
we how did we get a football coach that
is making the determination of what
funding and resources and approvals go
to the Pentagon like look I'll be the
first one to say that the Pentagon and
the funny we have for the you know
militarized complex we have way more
money and we can invest those types of
things in our actual country
and despite as much as Republicans want
to complain about money going to Ukraine
they'll never never suggest even they'll
go oh we got all these problems in
America why don't we uh put the funding
toward those things okay fine what's
your what's what's your proposal what is
your thing Margaret Taylor green no one
will actually take it seriously because
they don't actually want that wait wait
that would that would mean that you
would have to take her seriously exactly
but I'm just I'm just saying it's like
it's gonna be it's gonna be really
difficult right you need to take her
seriously it's just like the whole uh oh
gun violence the real solution is mental
health okay well let's invest in mental
health then let's get there whoa whoa no
no I was kidding I was kidding I didn't
actually mean that what I meant to say
was it's the same thing here what you
have is you have Republicans who are
unwilling to accept the the ability for
for women to have a right to Health Care
because they want their fascist policies
in place and as soon as you bring it up
they get all [__] offended and you
call them out for what they're doing
they go no that's not that's not what
we're really doing yeah but this doesn't
have to do about the health care in that
no one's paying it's about the leave
it's about paid leave so what they're
saying and I think this is essentially
what they're saying number one but I
think those two are inherently tied
together what what do you mean paid
leave and Healthcare what yet absolutely
their benefits right yeah but but one
isn't inherently a certain procedure
right right and then the reason why is
because some of these procedures are
being outlawed in these states that have
nothing to do
nothing to do with what you would
consider what they're saying oh my God
so so they're trying to kill babies
right as they come out I mean that's
what they're trying to do here that's
right they're trying I mean in that one
that one hearing that we watched the
other day with the guy who could barely
you know sit above the yep exactly uh
William Morgan when we watch that video
they're talking about changing the
phrasing or the wording of unborn baby
you know not fetus
should I do the show from down here yeah
I think so like we both we both could do
a show from down here
again
but you know the thing about the uh
[__] whispered into the microphone
the thing about the travel thing did you
catch that from Mike Pence he's like
look right now you're free like he's
almost like look right now women they're
kind of free to travel you know it's
crazy
stuff and it's almost like he's I feel
like he's projecting that that is like
look we don't want women in the military
and we definitely don't want women
crossing state lines yeah especially for
Health Care like we don't want them just
roaming around the country what are you
crazy
he might end up in a room alone with a
woman without mother uh if they're just
running around everywhere I mean he's
great you can't have you can't have
women wandering around that aren't on
leashes and aren't tied to the kitchen
aren't making me a sandwich aren't
Barefoot because you know if women are
in the military you know that's some
woke [__] right there even though it's
been happening it's been a part of the
military for years let me ask you
because you know that's kind of the
conservative thing like women need to be
running the household making sandwiches
like you said right sandwiches right you
know cleaning the floors making sure the
houses run spotless
like if you were gonna you know pinpoint
qualities of a person that you'd want to
be in leadership you know and run [__]
and like make sure [__] happens gets
cleaned up make sure it's perfect it
tastes great you know
what do you want people who you know you
assume that that would be their job yeah
when you want those people like running
things like government like you know
they do a damn good job running a
household I mean they keep everything
clean they never [__] anything up the
bills are always paid like we're always
on time for [__] that meals are always
cooked they're delicious [__] you
should you should see how this person
Cooks oh my God if they could make
policy like they make a [__] BLT bam
but wouldn't you see that these are
these are answering but they they don't
see through that right they don't see
that well they only look at you know
they look at women as transactional
property that's what they did say
they're they're yeah that's what I've
been trying to get up with the travel
thing yeah yeah yeah Mike Pence wants
women to not be in the military because
if you're in the military then you can't
be property right yeah and if you could
travel free
right if you if if a woman can travel
freely across state lines how the hell
are men going to own them yeah I mean
are they going to be men's properties
well if anything if anything you know a
good way to track them would be to give
all of these women coveted vaccines
because they've got the 5G chip to try
okay yeah that's true and it's like you
know it's like when you have a it's like
when you have a cat or a dog or a pet
and you get the microchipped it's kind
of like that you know right these
Republicans you would think you would
think that if they really want to track
these women to make sure they're not
going across state lines and not going
to do other certain things on their pay
time off or you know get an abortion
here or you know fulfilling their health
care needs somewhere else that they
would want to track them they would want
to say hmm we should we should give them
all the Jab
Mr stoner too dude
um on YouTube says girl they're coming
for you better vote because that's the
thing because today it's oh we don't
want to be in the military then it's
well it really we really shouldn't let
women travel across state lines to get
health care and then it's going to be
you know what we shouldn't do we should
we shouldn't have them vote because when
they vote they do things like give
themselves and protect their rights and
you know they do crazy things like that
well we can't oppress them and we can't
own them as property so we should really
make sure that they can't vote they
can't travel across state lines and we
definitely don't want them in the
military really any Institution for that
matter yeah we would prefer that they
not have jobs even yeah it would be much
easier and that's not to say that's not
to say that being a wife or a mother is
not I mean that's a full-time job hey
you know what is something that should
be respected but it shouldn't be
something that Republicans force on
women and say that's the only thing you
can do you know that's a good point
because there was several months ago
when we were in some of these Twitter
spaces and and it was you know this the
transgender talks it's kind of focused
around like oh I'm just Pro woman and
I'm Pro a woman of you know I want them
to be able to be a mom and this I'm like
look most people want women to be able
to make a choice of what they want their
life experience to be and not just women
anyone in general like that's really
what I want I want Liberty Freedom
Equity equality so if you want to be a
career woman and not have any children
that's your desire never get married
fine hey more power to you agreed but if
you want to be a woman you want to have
nine children with with the the husband
that you love and you want to practice
your Christian religion and you want to
indoctrinate those nine children into
that five whatever that's great freedom
of me you know you got the freedom in
this country I mean I think it's
ridiculous that you might do that but
that's my opinion that's just me you
think what I do is stupid I think what
you do is stupid but we both have the
Liberty to do stupid things as we see
fit speaking of stupid things oh my God
and speaking of people who love who
would love to own women as property I
mean who who better than the guy who
purposefully yeah would deflate the
tires and that how he met his wife well
let's let's
back up here Jesse Waters was married
had a wife oh oh so he was married he
was married okay all right there was
this assistant uh assistant producer
yeah that was you know uh that was on on
staff at Fox News yeah
he was being a creep was he being a
creep I mean he is a creep he would he
would Jesse Waters would deflate the
tires of his now
current wife
wait wait what happened to the first
wife did she not get her tires completed
Christian values and all that stuff yeah
she didn't get oh no dude she was she
was already property he didn't need her
anymore there wasn't the chase there
wasn't the grill anymore he wasn't
getting that adrenaline pump and to know
can I hunt for the prey right because
that's what he thinks of as women
they're just prey they're just objects
they're just when you're deflating their
tires so they can't go anywhere so you
have to you know hit on him and be
creepy in the parking lot that seems
like predatory type uh it's not it's not
a great sign when you have to purposely
deflate someone's tires so that then you
show up to their crown and go oh hey do
you need a ride to the wherever your
house and they go oh my God I don't know
what happened I got deflated Towers oh
don't we'll worry about it tomorrow
let's just go home oh you know what it's
actually kind of late let's get a hotel
and let's just pay cash actually if you
want could you cover this I'll I'll
immerse you in the expenses later I just
can't have my wife knowing that I'm here
with you right now classic you know you
know what else about Jesse water is this
funny
do you know how I got his name on Fox
News do you know what you know how he
did that because he cries well yeah no
he was on Bill O'Reilly show you
remember Bill O'Reilly
do it live do you remember why bill
right left Fox News though do you
remember that uh it was a sexual assault
yes oh yeah he was sexually assaulting
people women to be specific do you know
dude it's kind of crazy there's like a
it's like a theme at Fox pattern right
yeah so here's the thing is that the
Jesse Waters was the correspondent on
Bill Wright's show and his stick was he
would go around and he would like stalk
people and he would get in there you
know Alex Stein 99 yeah yeah he was like
Alex Stein before Alex Stein so he
wasn't this for the bill right he's not
a planet character he's just playing
himself yes he is a stalker yeah for
sure Jesse Waters a crazy stalker well
listen to what he says here this is uh
this is real I did not make this up I
did not edit this this is not AI I
promise you this was broadcast it's only
six seconds long but it's really as long
as Jesse Waters last in bed
[Music]
let's listen to Jesse Waters let's
listen to this profound report here on
Fox News so is the government
controlling the weather with laser beams
okay so Obama gay all right Obama gay in
1999 and government controlling weather
with laser beams this is it's almost it
is almost what
like Fox anyone who comes out of Fox
News I mean there's a couple people
maybe who can actually have a
conversation without having to blurt a
bunch of lies and misinformation but if
you look at the if you look at the
running cast members at Fox News it
makes me feel like everything that they
produce is as if the National Enquirer
was put to TV right you're like do
aliens that's literally what they're
doing now yeah they have to to keep
people viewing you look at Tucker
Carlson the guy is desperately trying to
keep his ratings
ratings right on on Twitter which by the
way if people don't know this Elon
reached out to Tucker's team right after
he was let go to tell him you should
come over to Twitter you should do a
video over here you should do a show
over here so then Tucker was like okay
I'll do a couple shows so he released
these 10 12 13 10 11 minutes they did
worse and worse and worse and they kept
doing worse and then he's like you know
what I need I need to release longer
more provocative more controversial
episodes all [__] yep yeah and then
hey look up again and then Elon also at
the same time was like oh you know what
we need to remove the ability for people
to actually see what the real video
metrics are so what the Real views are
and let's re-label that from Impressions
to views right so anytime you scroll
through it on your feed it's not an
actual view it's an impression and not
only that but the only way to get a real
video view is to wash something for at
least two seconds and if anyone knows
how Twitter [__] works it's like 80d
on [__] crack okay you you there's no
way to focus this is the same kind of
crack that Barack Obama was smoking in
1999 okay good yeah for 250 or how much
Larry Sinclair game I was I was just
checking no yeah I know of course of
course but honestly if anyone knows how
Twitter is your your focus and your your
concentration is so small and finite
where you're I and I'm guilty of it I'm
I'm thinking about what was that I'm
like oh that's right I gotta look for
this thing then I'm going over here I'm
looking for tweets to like you know to
back up what I'm saying then I'm looking
for this and it's I'm only able to like
pick up one thing at a time before I'm
able to fully digest it in just a minute
you're like a squirrel honestly with a
whole field of nuts you're like it's
like the swirl I don't want to say I've
got nuts in my mouth but you know oh you
guys come on
oh so it's not just Barack Obama is it
man you know it's like so what what Gabe
said Sanchez would or wouldn't do for
some Coke and some crack on a CD on a CD
case okay
I'm just saying I'm just saying nothing
wrong with a couple nuts on your face or
in your mouth you know as long as you're
a squirrel and they're appropriate yeah
you know as long as you're a squirrel
right no no not as long as you're if you
want nuts in your mouth put nuts in your
mouth
this is a [__] marriage this is
America for crying out loud I just love
I just love that Tucker Carlson's like
oh I'm really gonna get Obama now he's
gay okay one this story has been
debunked several times Larry Sinclair
has the [__] shadiest past if anyone
wants to look into Larry Sinclair and
everything that he's done previously
like broad broad forgery fraud flying
super long rap sheet he ran for Florida
mayor at one point hilarious in many
regards whoa whoa so he's I didn't I
didn't catch that detail so this is like
Joe Exotic yeah yeah yeah well except
Joe Exotic head bigger aspirations and
dreams right he wanted it either way
they both they both will not financially
recover from this I'll tell you huh that
is true that is true speaking of balls
in your mouth
what
this guy dude okay Mike Huckabee do you
think Mike Gaga B has never had a set of
nuts in his mouth oh I'm sure I'm sure
sure sure I mean I'm not saying I know
I'm just saying that there's probably
someone out there that would be willing
to say that he has in 1999. oh yeah
sweaty balls people want to know are
they sweaty balls
chin nuts sweaty but like I said like I
said in a previous what was that
Mike Huckabee looks like he is the
wish.com version
of Ernest Hemingway
you can't I'm telling you you did not
have the beer as soon as he got the
grand
as soon as these guys grew beards
they've created a whole new alter egos
or like uh doppelgangers if people look
up people look up Ernest Hemingway right
now and you compare that to the video
we're about to play you'll be like yep
that is for sure a cheap version of
Ernest Hemingway uh so they're saying
over here on Discord it looks like Rico
says
um remember when this guy ran for
president what a [__] joke the
Republican party oh man Jesus Christ
what a [__] joke now you're gonna
you're gonna
this video is wild stuff and the reason
why it's wild is not only is Mike
Huckabee Mike Huckabee who ran for
president of the United States but he's
a former governor of of Arkansas and his
daughter who is who was the uh who was
the official liar at the white smokey
eye yes smokey eye and they they were
which by the way no one should get
offended by that joke yeah I'm right
they were hanging out with Tits McGee
this over the weekend you know I'm
talking about you know the picture I'm
talking about
yes I do and the fact that boss and
Brian didn't know the the right person
to Seinfeld I think he's in the chat
today if you're still listening Brian at
that moment I had it I was on work calls
and I happened to uh
I just jumped in for that moment and I
caught the sign it was a great moment to
witness right the the the uh I think I
sent you I think I think yeah you said a
lot well I think I think it got dropped
on Discord yeah yeah
anyway but anyways if Brian's still here
man you need to get on that episode and
watch that the manzier episode so we can
talk about it next time uh but you know
here is the uh wish.com as gabes's uh
Ernest Hemingway I think he grew this
beard to hide his his balls on his chin
you know a lot of people
you know well that or the the neck Gina
that's something yeah well you know
balls chin you know I kind of Wonder I
kind of wonder what Donald Trump would
look like if he grew a beer listen all
the boxes Jump Right In hid the boxes in
neck China Nick jaina I don't know I
just wanna I just want to know what it
would be like if Donald Trump grew a
beard out just you think he would grow a
beard just to cover up the neck Gina do
you think he could grow a beard yeah
Trump
I saw someone in the Discord so I had to
do it yeah no I see that everyone's like
stop talking about the Discord I'm like
well go over there and see these jungles
in there and talk about it it's [__]
crazy in the Discord chat because
they're posting memes and gifts and oh
[__] it's crazy over there but here's
what made me alive I won't it's a shitty
it's a shitty timeline that we're in but
this is the time that we're in so we
might as well have fun while we're doing
it uh but here's Mike Huckabee let's
listen to this clip I'm gonna show it to
you I promise I'm I'm gonna play it do
you know how political opponents to
those in power are dealt with in third
world dictatorships he's like he's like
hey hey I've studied this and I'm I'm
excited about us doing this to people oh
man I can't wait I can't wait for us to
be a Banana Republic had to be quite
honest I still love talking about Banana
Republic I want to know how many
Republicans
think that Banana Republic is the store
that everyone's talking about they
hundred percent they're like Banana
Republic and it's like hi with you I
went to the Banana Republic over the
weekend it's in vagina town I cannot
believe that the Banana Republic is in
Vagina Town oh my God these [__]
chuckleheads but listen to this listen
to what he says about ballots
and bullets and a republican communist
regimes well it's simple
people in power use their police
agencies to arrest their opponents for
made-up crimes an attempt to discredit
them right bankrupt them imprison them
Exile them are all of the above it seems
like he's doing like this is like
material for right Wingers to jerk off
to it's like yeah that's what we want
babies
put these Communists and [__] gitmo
yeah baby like that's what it no you
gotta put him on a barge outside of
gitmo oh okay because remember that's
the whole yeah that's true you know that
Jenny Thomas thinks [__] crazy
but it seems like they're they're
creating you know uh hate masturbate uh
material here you know somebody somebody
reminded me in the Discord you know it's
funny when when all of these Republicans
get busted for something there's always
a photo of them with a republican
politician you know whether it's Enrique
atario being with all these people or or
uh Joe Biggs
but the one specifically is Mike
Huckabee with uh Josh Duggar yeah yeah
the the the uh 35 kids and molesting
I've been counting sorry yeah you know
no I I think that's what the show's
called what it like 35 kids in molesting
yeah that's something crazy like that
that should be a spoof Christian value
okay that should be a smooth 35 kids and
molesting oh my god
um well here's here's Mike Huckabee to
finish up about how he's gonna murder
his political opponents because there's
not gonna be elections anymore because
he that's what they want but listen
and if you're not paying attention
Joe Biden is using exactly those tactics
to make sure that Donald Trump is not
his opponent in 2024. here's the problem
if these tactics end up working to keep
Trump from winning or even running into
winning accountability it is going to be
the last American election that will be
decided by ballots rather than bullets
so there it is there it is Mike
Huckabee's thinking that oh if Donald
Trump doesn't get to win if Donald Trump
if I if Donald Trump doesn't get to win
then we're going to decide each election
from now on with bullets bullets are
gonna be ballots ballots are gonna be
bullets and you're not gonna have you're
not going to have early bulleting you're
not going to have that you're not going
to have that we don't like we want paper
bullets we want paper bullets what the
[__] is wrong with these people
I have no idea it's I mean the the
this is this is honestly like channel
what channel is this on it says TBN is
that to to be nonsense or I don't know
TBN is the wannabe TVs
that's the channel you know it's like
TBN what does TBN stand for TV they're
like it's it's not s it's not South it's
north the Taliban broadcast network is
that what it is could be
I just look at this segment oh here it
is ah here it is it's Trinity
Broadcasting Network it's a Christian
how Christian of him by the way how
Christian yeah these bullets God God God
wrote God wrote Jesus on the bullets
these people these Republicans who who
push push these ideas of like oh look I
it's funny because when they say things
like look I don't want to have to
threaten you right now but I'm just
saying if something goes wrong
just know that it's not my fault okay
it's not my fault and someone recently
if anyone remembers this uh the Georgia
state senator Donald Trump's new BFF
Colton Moore
yeah yeah oh yeah we talked about him
last week or this week I don't remember
yeah last year I I mean last last year
last week it feels like last year
doesn't it it's honestly insane but I
put him I put him in the last episode of
what was that but in that in that
segment and in the video that he has
he's on uh
he's talking about how
he's like look I don't I don't want to
have to show up with my rifle but I will
and it's like whoa whoa whoa no one ever
mentioned guns how did you even come to
this position of having to require or
like requiring a gun
to show up and defend your position
there's no reason to threaten anyone
with a [__] but but Gabe that's
that's what I've been trying to tell the
audience for years is that it's it's a
white gun culture and the white gun
culture is if I've got a problem
whatever that probably doesn't matter it
does not listen to me it does not matter
what problem it is a gun will fix it a
gun will fix it because it says in the
Second Amendment right there you have
the right to carry him and it's only
thing that can fix any problem that a
white guy has it says it right there in
the Second Amendment so related to what
Taija said they don't masturbate they
hate it do you think that they also
get off on shooting a load out of their
gun
yes 100 okay 100 how you're shooting a
load while shooting alone right right
well and you know these are the same
people who hater bait they speak
Vietnamese too oh yeah fluent it's
almost like that's their first language
right victims they come out and they're
like oh no no no no no do they iterate
to the victimies though
um I think that they play it back they
listen to themselves they listen to
themselves
play victim and they go oh yeah that's
it right there oh yeah that's the stuff
baby
girl that's a spot
money shot oh that's the spot uh Derek
Derek bought me a shot if I had a shot
Derek I'd take it thank you Derek for
buying a round of Jaeger there oh yeah
well today oh today's Thursday should
have happened yesterday no well hey man
I I've been getting shots on Sundays and
I took several of them last night a few
Kidman Phil I took silver in those shots
last night Canada I can't tell speaking
of someone who needs a [__] shot now
and then Jesus Christ would she she just
needs to chill the [__] out listen to
this [__] about January 6th you know
this this is after Enrique I need to see
this I just read that you want to see it
yeah the Chiron says um would Trump
pardon proud boys Enrique atario did you
have for 22 years after January 6 riots
um this is talk TV I think I think I
think what it should say is would Trump
pardon crybabies yeah that's true
because I have get to see them put me in
prison please please you have to see any
of these proud boys Oath Keepers or
other white supremacists you know Nazis
that show up and do not
end up crying or showing an incredible
amount of remorse in the courtroom to
say no no no please please please victim
means victim means please please please
please please please please please
please please please please please no
[__] I have yet to see it so when
they say proud boys I say crybabies cry
babies okay well here you know what's
significant about this that I'm noticing
is she is not using that that filter
that [__] whack you mean you mean the
Vaseline on the camera looks like she
cleaned it off she's yeah and and you
thought she was at her house but she's
actually
sitting in a city somewhere and it's
[__] weird Okay let's listen to what
um
the uh the the delusional
self-proclaimed governor of Arizona
she's still on that kick didn't she
she's still like no I'm gonna be the guy
no yes she's still she's still you know
she's not coping yet she's still in this
world where
she thinks that she won yeah well listen
to what she says about the January 6
Insurrection where they tried to
overthrow the government of the United
States and Enrique HRA was just jail and
it's sentenced to 22 years for doing it
that much uh just recently and they were
getting terrorist enhancements so
they're not only they're not only
insurrectionists they're domestic
terrorists they're convicted of it now
so let's listen to what the wax paper uh
filter lady has to say
well I think Americans are coming around
to the fact that it wasn't an
Insurrection it was a staged Riot it was
a staged ride to cover up the fact that
they were going to certify a fraudulent
election and and here we're taking all
of these people many of them did nothing
wrong sentencing them to long sentences
in the DC Gulag on January 6. it wasn't
as the media described it it was not
Insurrection and many of the people were
encouraged to go in by FBI informants
this is this is hilarious this is
hilarious because they're literally
playing her saying this as they're
playing footage of these people doing
what she's saying they didn't do
okay yeah that's cool
um it's really [__] weird stuff where
she's like the American people are
finally coming around to believing the
nonsense that we've been selling even
though they just watched not only The
Oath Keepers get sentenced to to dozens
and of of decades AIDS in prison now the
proud boys have dozens of decades in
prison for seditious conspiracy with the
terrorist enhancement huh the American
people are really coming around all
these lights like shut the [__] up what
are you talking about man what the [__]
are you talking about like literally
literally they're convicted of the [__]
that you're saying they're they didn't
do yeah in sentences and it's also funny
because you know like everyone you know
a good example of this is Vivek
ramaswamy but it's the ability for them
to
see literal footage
of the thing that they're talking about
which is disproving or debunking the
claim that they're making and still
being able to say no no see you don't
understand what really happened was
it's
truly truly amazing I mean Carrie Lake
you know
her ability to to not accept reality and
still live in this world that is like I
won the election and I know exactly what
happened and it was all fake and this
and that and these people who went to
the went to the January 6th Insurrection
I mean at the January 6th uh protest uh
were not were not domestic terrorists
again while they play footage other
people actually committing the crimes
well you know speaking of people
I like to lie about this and this seems
to be it seems to be that there's this
um there's this effort to push this idea
that don't believe what what the
sentences say like don't believe what
the jury convicted them of don't believe
any of that stuff here's Sarah Palin
when can we get to him hold on hold on
is she in her she's got a is she on an
archery range I well I don't know this
she's in her backyard it might be with
the Target and the best what is going on
back there you couldn't have found a a
better place to have a [__] interview
here or to go to the backyard at least
move the target like what is going on in
front of the target see I want people
know every once in a while I move my
head like this so where you can see
these wires see those wires right there
I don't hide the wires because I can
just be in front of them you see that
you see that that's what you also don't
hide the shadow dong because I mean
everyone loves the [__] Shadow dick
yeah why they love they love the shadow
but I mean I'm hiding the cables because
I certainly could hide these in a
different way yeah why when I could just
position myself directly in front yeah
and never once while I'm like this I'm
like oh there's the cables oh there they
are
you could honestly just you know she
could if she didn't want to move the
Target right she could have just angled
it this is slightly over but who knows
what she's actually hiding behind her
head right could she could be a dead
body it could be it could be it could be
now this is Sarah Payne and for all
those people who uh willingly forgot who
this [__] idiot is
um understandably so I mean you know I
actually my comment to this video had
nothing to do with like the instructions
I was just like when can we [__] when
can we in this country have permission
to forget who this [__] [__] is yeah
I mean she tried she tried recently when
she ran for the Senate and got [__]
owned right well that's they were like
oh oh it was it was the way Alaska votes
Alaska can a chain of laws and now I
can't get elected because
because the election laws and and I
can't I can't now get elected because uh
alaskans get to pick their
representatives in a different way and
it's actually better now
and ranked Choice voting she probably if
she never if she never joined John
McCain's ticket she probably would have
been able to successfully have her term
and stay on that and even later run and
be more successful but uh
you know the best part about it well you
know
don't you know don't you know you know
the best part about Sarah Palin the best
part about her and this is really for
Alaska more than America but but Alaska
when she failed and she failed miserably
she quit so she's a quitter which was
good for Alaska because why would you
want this person in charge of anything
I've never backed down from a fight you
literally quit right you did that
surrender it's always the best dish yet
because it's always with these [__]
idiots but let's listen to Sarah Palin's
um copycat of Carrie lake is Carrie Lake
the wish.com Sarah Palin or Sarah Palin
wish.com no no Lauren bobert is the
wish.com of Sarah Palin oh okay and uh
what's her face out of Utah is the
wish.com version of Kerry Lake okay okay
it's all confusing yeah I forget what
her name is I'm blinking our name but
she's the one who replaced uh Liz Cheney
not Utah you mean Wyoming oh Wyoming
yeah yeah you know they all kind of they
all blend together over there tomato
Tomatoes over there they just kind of
they all look the same on the map you
know oh man that's rough I guess I guess
it's been a while since you've taken uh
geography in high school huh well you
know haven't had to travel much okay I
mean not that I was really traveling to
that area of the U.S right you know
Wyoming's beautiful yeah you talk I'm
not saying I'm not saying it's not I've
been to Utah we've been over this we
went over this time and time again Utah
is one of the gayest places in the
country yeah yeah which Utah it's shot
like cities supposedly yeah I went to
Salt Lake City I went to Sunday was it
pretty gay as gay as Obama I mean dude
it was like every I was like trying to
like fight off people and then other
people they were just walking down
Suburban streets it was crazy oh really
so there's people like outside walking
around yeah and it was also during the
winter so it was like what this is crazy
they're just trying to stay warm I guess
sounds sounds pretty gay to me okay
let's let's go let's go to Sarah Palin
here about her lies about the
Insurrection and uh they weren't even
able to hijack the terminology being
used that is commonplace now when we
talk about January 6th the definition of
insurrection that's all about violence
that's overthrowing a government and
here that now is in just you know
commonplace vernaculars being used it
wasn't an Insurrection on those people
who wanted to get into the capitol
please stop talking besides they're
right shut the [__] up to protest to
voice their opinion and the the ones who
is she really saying anything though no
she's not and it hurts my head Tony it
hurts my like I can I can stand watching
Trump say a bunch of weird [__] where he
just like Rambles on but sometimes
I mean I was able to do it for what was
that but like looking at Sarah Palin I'm
just like what the [__] are you talking
about there's nothing Insurrection not
Insurrection but seeing a lot of stuff
and that stuff doesn't mean anything
and the fact and and I love the Chiron
where it was like can you go back it
says they threw the book at Jan six yeah
uh so I got it right I gotta rewind it
here let's see oh yeah here it is okay
two parts two parts okay right here
facing extremely an extremely long time
in jail all right go to the next part
boohoo commit crimes do the time then it
says
the government has thrown the book at
most gen six writers now script and
expert is that like the Bible is that
the book they're talking about yeah the
the the book yeah
several Jan six defendants are facing
harsher senses than some murderers okay
let's just back up a second I want
people to understand the reality of
what's going on people committed crimes
they are now having to do said times now
here's here is the thing
the doj said hey we recommend
this sensing and the judge says I don't
really think it should be that way
Tony can you tell me who appointed the
judge who sentenced Enrique tario the 22
years and you know years that's a good
point I think it was the guy who beat
the email lady I don't remember it was
like 2016. it's a pretty thing is she
the email lady said that uh don't elect
him because he'll probably destroy our
country because his followers are
deplorables who was that guy
um so you're saying that guy appointed
this judge that yeah oh my God that's
horrible that's it's that seems like
crazy State type stuff you know what
maybe that person who appointed that
judge is part of the deep State could be
but I'm look all I'm saying is that if
you're if you're worried if you're if
you're if you are worried and distressed
at the fact that
Enrique tario just got 22 years and
three years of supervised supervision
then you have to kind of take it up with
the big guy that being Trump since he's
the one that appointed him
and I just I just want to point out that
uh Huffy mcpaint Mick painter here she
seems like she Huffs paint doesn't she I
mean she she's got some brain damage I
feel like she's a little bit high right
now and she's like oh I'm on Newsmax
okay um Jan sticks there's long
sentencing unfair Donald Trump is being
illegally persecuted by Merrick Garland
and Jack Smith and let me tell you uh uh
we need to bring guns to the ballots
and and Insurrection not real yeah
that's the thing like again this is one
of those moments where you
at one point you would say ah this is
this is a joke this is this is a parody
of our current situation Genie Genie
says lead paint if she's huffing paint
it definitely is [__] he's like hey
have you guys tried these pain chips
they're free
[Laughter]
speaking of people who eat paint chips
um you know I don't want to transition
here we go remember I played I have not
seen it but this screen grab is great it
is um but well look at the Chiron here
um just pay attention to it here's
here's the thing is
the other day when I played the video of
her talking about how much taxes were
during the Ice Age I was like
you know I can't get any stupider the
answer is always yeah with her yes
stupider is a thing she will be always
and forever the stupid
let's listen to this stupidity
is charging president Trump and others
in the state of Georgia with and this is
what I want to do I want to make sure
that the Republican party never ever
forgets because we need to be sure to
come after these people when we win the
White House in 2024 and I'm going to
tell you something right now Eric we are
going to win and when we win and we take
charge of the Department of Justice and
the FBI those agencies need to be gutted
they need to be gutted of the Communists
that are doing this to Americans and did
she did she does she know What
communists are great you know what this
sounds like this sounds like McCarthyism
2.0 we're gonna go yeah
this is way Dumber this is way Dumber
because you're like 100 we can't believe
that they're weaponizing the government
against Donald Trump and the former
president but as soon as we take power
that's exactly what I do we're gonna
weaponize the government against the
former president of the United States
Joe Biden and we're gonna lock all the
Communist stuff we're gonna get rid of
those communist it almost feels like
there was a time in history and there
was like a country in Europe
he's it feels like it was like um it was
like there was a war over this thing
where there was there was this guy with
a small little mustache Lindsay yeah
remember this yeah like a little like it
looked like a like the shape of a Lego
right and it feels like they did
feels like to me that we already did
this uh almost 100 years ago where where
they would demonize people who weren't
Communists but calling them Communists
even though because they don't know What
communists are yeah it feels like how
are they going to I would love to know
what the
review
you know qualifications and also the uh
uh the way in which they're gonna scan
through every employee in the federal
government and say
if they were Kami or not
I just wanted I just want a communist is
how are they gonna figure out is it a
Marxist a communist is it uh you know
it's a democratic Zone like whatever you
know it's the ability for them to go I
just want to know I honestly want to
know like what are what are going to be
the metrics they use or you know what
have you that they analyze each person
to say
you know it's um
and so what's the it's like [__]
Dianetics from Scientology it's a
machine where they hold it and they're
like oh this is stress test and based on
what you are is you know yeah that's
what I imagine that's right that's their
confessions or whatever yeah yeah I mean
that's what they they blackmail them all
[__] but they have these little machines
in the whole anyway it sounds like
you've been in the Church of Scientology
I have been in the church Scientology
have you really in New York City did you
really yeah I went in there by China
Square I had a crazy experience where a
woman told me about how she used to do
crack and meth and then what yeah wait
just wait a second hold on hold on we
only got like nine minutes left
yeah yeah all right look I went to Times
Square I was in New York performing at
an Improv Festival yeah and I was there
for the weekend and I was like ah well
I'm bored in between shows so I'm gonna
go to the Scientology uh church it's in
at least at I'm sure it's still there
it's off of Times Square you go there
you walk in and then at first they're
like hey well can I help you with
something and I was like no I I'm just
looking around
walked around I felt like I was in the
the waiting room of a like a
chiropractor or a doctor's office or
something like it wasn't like a big
building it's just like a little office
no it's a it's a tall building they've
got other floors that you can't get
access to but when you walk in there's a
whole like museum museum Gallery space
but they have all these screens that
have a bunch of these quotes right from
L Ron Hubbard and then they have these
like they have this like very like
essential sounds amazing you know like
relaxing music and so then you walk
through and they've got the stories and
these different people and then I had
this woman that came up to me she's like
hey can I help you and I was like no I'm
good I'm just
just looking around I'm curious never
been here and she's like oh are you
considering like joining the church and
I was like
I don't really know yet she had you at
the second sentence like hey dude yeah
and I was like I was like I was like I
don't I don't I don't I don't really I
don't really uh I think I'm okay I don't
really know yet and she was like oh well
let me tell you about my experience I
used to be addicted to meth and crack
cocaine now I'm totally sober I found
the Church of Scientology and they
helped me recover blah blah blah long so
short she paid a bunch of money and she
got into it and now she's you know so
are you a Scientologist now that's all I
wanted yes and Tom Cruise is the best
somebody said why did I not just go to
the one in La I have been to the one in
La I have not been inside that's like
that's like the headquarters isn't it
like there's the main I live not too far
from both both locations that's the one
that elderon Hubbard that's where he was
at like the big blue one that's the one
there like I can tell you I once tried
to go down L Ron Hubbard Street on my
bicycle to cut to go over to the gym
because it was a closer cut through wait
wait you cut through the the cult alley
to get to the gym yeah okay pretty much
and what ended up happening was uh the
security guard stopped me that one guy
came out of the building didn't look
like Tom Cruise with this thing no they
have no I didn't know that like Tom
Cruise looked like this on the security
guards but it's funny they have that
they look like the people who who live
and work there not security they look
like like flight attendants and they
also carry these briefcases they're the
semen aren't they like literally it's
isn't it semen it's so weird it's so
weird I don't know man I didn't want to
know don't get your minds in the gutter
not like come yeah like I want to like
semen I'm gonna come like on the Sea on
the sea but they then I had a security
guard who stopped me at the end of the
block who was like oh what are you doing
over here and I was like oh I'm just cut
two to go to the gym and he goes yeah
this is private property and I was like
oh is it I don't know maybe it could be
this private property [__] you're gonna
have to join the cult if you want to
come through here okay if you ever want
to come through here again
um I'm gonna come and I was like I'm
gonna come and
oh my God so wait a second
I I just want to get this clear because
it feels like to me that you have a past
with Scientology that you have not told
us about
yeah I've had some encounters with
scientologists
and I have I have not disclosed that to
the public I know well those are just a
couple stories this seems like a
controversy that may you know that may
come back and bite Us in the long run
that you're a who knows you may or may
not be so let me ask you when you went
into the New York one because this is
this is like the image that I have when
you go in like when you came out like
when you came out there did it feel like
you were like in a dark bar all night
long and you come in it's morning time
uh did you need like do you feel like
you needed a shower or what was the
feeling when you walked out when I
walked out I looked around to see who
was looking at me really you were like
oh that guy just joined me well just
because I was like clearly it's got a
huge it's got a vertical Scientology
sign on the side and so you know what it
is like it's across from other bars and
other like so it's not like you just
stumbled into it accidentally no no I
knew what I was looking for I know but
everyone else when you come in yeah that
guy just accidentally walked in it's not
like a non-descript building like it's
clearly identified as the Church of
Scientology it's there you know what it
is when you walk in and when you walk
out of it and people who see people you
know go in and out but when you're
inside it was
not like well lit it was
uh I would say it was had some like
spotlights here and there and then most
of lighting was on the walls and the TV
screens so it was like again it really
felt like they were trying to create
this like relaxing environment where you
hear this music and then you see these
screens with different quotes and
different statements and then somebody
just happens to appear behind you and
goes are you ready to convert to the
Church of Scientology
speaking of people trying to [__] us
yesterday uh Grandpa poopy pants on the
Hugh Hewitt show this is hilarious and
I'm sad that we only have five minutes
to talk about this
um but I wanted well you asked the
question about scientology I know I know
I just wanted to know if you were a
Scientologist or not I was trying to get
to the bottom of a groundbreaking story
that could possibly you know break open
the what was that uh according to G uh
to Jalen yeah let's take it from a
native New Yorker nobody's watching you
leave except the Scientologist and guess
what they're probably still watching me
right outside like that guy was in the
is in the New York church at one point
um here's Donald Trump trying to um tell
Hugh Hewitt that he moved the boxes
without telling him
he moves the boxes in committed crime
this is wild [__] listen to this did you
direct anyone to move the boxes Mr
President did you tell anyone to move
the boxes up
anything you know why because I'm
allowed to do whatever I want I come
under the presidential records act I'm
not telling you you know okay okay so
he's like he's like I'm not saying I
never say anything dude that is all you
do is say stuff like you just if you
don't say it here you're gonna make a
video where you're gonna say it later
right but he's but he's he's like
because what do you Hewitt is trying to
get Donald Trump to do in this interview
is tell him did he direct someone to
move the boxes and he's like no I didn't
direct anybody I wouldn't do that I did
it myself you wouldn't think that I
could lift boxes but I can live I'm not
I'm not a vagina I can lift boxes no now
listen to when he gets to the part about
obstruction and going to court and
testifying this is the juicy stuff and
we want to push Donald Trump this is
exactly what we want to have happen
listen every time I talk to you oh I
have a break or if you don't have any
story I come under the presidential
records act I'm allowed to do everything
I did we
will you testify in your own defense yes
please please absolutely yes oh yes
absolutely yes yes of course he's not
going to actually oh no he's not gonna
man I really hope he does you know how
awesome that would be we talked about it
before the Murdoch trial what is it
North Carolina South Carolina the guy
Alex
dude that morning the first time I ever
heard of that story was when I was
watching the judge that morning spend 45
minutes to talk Alec Murdock of not
getting on the stand he's like look this
is a big [__] mistake this jury is
definitely gonna think you're guilty if
you get on that stand do you still want
to do it he's like oh absolutely oh yeah
yeah I think I'm the only one who can
tell my story right no no no no you
don't please don't do this okay the
judge asked his attorney he's like have
you advised him not to do this like yes
absolutely he should not do this he will
totally look guilty if he gets up there
and the judge is like did you are you
taking your your lawyer's advice and
again it's like absolutely and you still
want to do this you still want to look
guilty as hell yes I want to do that but
I I would applaud Donald Trump getting
on the stand but listen to this yeah
dude don't be a little baby yeah great
don't be it done
yeah yeah all right let's listen to how
he tells you Hewitt what he would
respond to when prosecutors ask him
about the boxes
and I would do that I look forward to
because that's just like Russia Russia
Russia that's all the same information
it was a political report for that by
Hillary Clinton the DNC they paid
Millions for it they gave it to
Christopher Steele they paid millions
and million dollars for it and it was
all fake I think that obstruction charge
is going to get the trial Mr President
so he was trying to get him back on
track because Trump gets Way Off Track
he's like the P Cape was it real it was
there never was a p-tape trust me I know
no B tape at some point I hope that
somebody who's interviewing whenever he
brings up the steel dossier he's like
you mean the p-tape and then just let it
let's see how he responds to just the
phrase P tape right right well so he
asked him the question and this is a
very important question and I usually
don't like you Hewitt but Hugh Hewitt
asking this question I think is
important because now we have him on
record sort of I guess
um saying what he would say if the
prosecutor's asking because Hugh it's
right here this obstruction charge is
gonna go to a jury it may not be this
year it may not be next year eventually
though there is a point in time where
Donald Trump is going to be sitting in a
courtroom and that obstruction charge
for the documents which is the most one
of the easiest slam dunk charges I think
in that entire indictment
um is going to be in front of a jury but
listens to what the question is and then
the answer
okay if you do and they ask you on on
the stand did you order anyone to move
boxes how will you answer
I'm not answering that question for you
but I'm totally covered under the laws
presidential records Zach
just read it you take a look at it I'm
totally covered under the law
it's civil now Biden had no civil act
the things he did are criminal but that
he doesn't have a deranged person on his
case you know they gave me deranged Jack
Smith
he's like he's like look I didn't I
didn't direct anyone I'm not telling you
that I directed anyone to move the boxes
because I did okay and it's not a crime
though even though they're charging me
that I can't tell you because it is a
crime I'm totally covered under
presidential records act it's clear what
his [__] he's like well Kenny and
she's like I'm not gonna tell you I
don't have to tell you what's mine is
mine you're not gonna find out okay and
it's just the fact that he's like
any I just want to point out too that
anyone who goes on Hugh Hewitt's show
yeah ends up saying the dumbest [__]
they can say they end up telling on
themselves uh Herschel Walker did it way
back when when he was talking about
these these illegitimate chill or not
illegitimate but these children that
they had out of wedlock you know the
hidden children that he had children
he's like let me hide them in the closet
these boxcar kids so when you have this
moment here Donald Trump being like I'm
not gonna tell you look I just I'll go
on the stand but I'm not gonna tell you
right here right now and when I actually
do get on this dead I'm not gonna say it
either I'm gonna say presidential
records act it's so stupid it's like
boo-boo stick your head in doo-doo
whatever bounces off me it sticks to you
that would be so odd can you imagine him
saying that mystery books he's on the
stand and he says [__] like he's like
he's like Milo there my excuse me excuse
me rude rude my lawyer has advised me to
tell you that I'm Rubber and your glue
and whatever bounces off of me sticks to
you it's collusion collusion collusion
Joe Biden is a criminal and that's why
we're here we're all here in this
courtroom because Joe Biden is Joe
Budden let me tell you about Joe and let
me tell you about Hunter Biden what
about that laptop huh collusion Ukraine
Ukraine Russia Russia Russia fake
dossier
it's gonna be awesome I so hope this
chucklehead gets on the stand oh yeah I
hope that they ask him and then somebody
says well on September 6 2023 on the
Hugh Hewitt show you said that you would
go on
uh sure there's record here let me let
me play the tape for you and see if
you'll go ahead and answer this is this
is fantastic it's great I can't wait um
for accountability to rain down on this
[__] I really can't wait I can't
wait for it I don't know how soon it's
gonna be
um but it's gonna be soon and we're
never gonna leave the story we're not
and remember another reminder of our
schedule changing with huge expansion
here at the [__] em fam and the [__] em
Universe the new schedule is that after
our Tuesday Wednesday Thursday show so
if this was next week Thursday what you
would do is you're on the YouTube
channel you would stay right here and it
would go right to what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez the guy with the last
name Sanchez
so next Thursday next Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday uh Gabe will have a show for
one hour that is what was that live with
Gabe Sanchez right after our show so
you're gonna want to make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel right
now you're not going to want to miss
that and you're also going to want to go
to the Tony michaels.com scroll down
scroll all the way down and you'll find
Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel you're
definitely going to want to subscribe
there because it will be a show you'll
get directed right to the show but it'll
be on two separate channels so you're
going to want to make sure to subscribe
to Gabe's Channel and the attorney
Michael I just put I just put the
channel inside of in the chat chat I'll
throw it in a Discord right now as well
awesome yeah so uh if you uh and I'll
put the Discord uh Link in the chat uh
go to the Discord it's in there as well
I know
um a lot of people are joining the
Discord also if you decide to join the
Discord and go over there make sure
you're verifying when you enter the
Discord I go to the Welcome Center it'll
give you directions if you're having
trouble it also tells you what to do if
you're having trouble there as well so
just go to the Welcome Center when you
get into this scored if you're if you're
having trouble verifying they're just
verifying to make sure you're a human
but get in on the live chat over there
we're gonna do a lot of events new stuff
going on and also um don't forget I'll
be announcing I'm gonna make a moderator
interest uh form where you guys can sign
up if you're interested in being a
moderator uh we're just collecting names
at this point we know because there's a
huge expansion we have a great moderator
team but we know the more content we're
adding the more moderators we possibly
might need in the future so if anyone's
considering or wants to be considered to
be a moderator on platforms I'll have a
forum for you to fill out I have a link
I'll put it on the website and then I'll
let you guys know on YouTube Twitter and
that sort of stuff when you can go over
and click on that link and fill that
format if you're interested in that and
also tomorrow's Friday so we have
bonehead of the week oh yeah
a week so you'll be voting tonight I
gave um I I surmised this earlier I
think we should cut the Twitter poll and
probably do a poll if we can if we can
in uh in this Discord yeah I think we'll
do a poll on Discord and then uh the
poll on YouTube because Twitter [__]
sucks it's horrible it's horrible all
right you know that's what no no no yeah
that's what happens
in this crazy ass timeline
baby same time same place tomorrow don't
forget keep your keep your dial on
because next week's gonna be big changes
but you're gonna have three hours for
three days a week
live free
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Tony Michaels
podcast what was that live with Gabe
Sanchez three hours on the [__]
Universe for the [__] fam but
tomorrow we'll be here it's a bonehead
of the week same time same place Surf's
Up [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon